and Litton elephant proved Munir that
day well it's been the troll today we
got to play calm time it's probably not
gonna be a content considering this game
was made by one of the same guys who
made I'm scared and I'm scared was
[ __ ] scary I'm not even writing pants
for this one mess I'm serious do you
want luck you can't do back let's go uh
I like I live in this small cottage
isolated from Silence is law in such a
place I can walk my home is almost
something I can to an inescapable prison
while the chirping of the sparrows and
the breath of the wind on my soul
company I like the sound of the wind
[Music]
what god I hate these pixel games what
are you you don't like what I think
you're green haired man I don't like it
well that makes two of us mr. greeny all
right
that's a ugly-ass paint hey hey nice
haircut man hi
then you'll notice that girl in the
kitchen I'm a hit on her man this part
is such a bore when are there other
guests supposed to come okay let's look
at this a girl mmm
she looks valuable lace she looks like
she's on a very strict diet holy [ __ ]
indeed um do you know if that man with a
suit jacket it's mad look at her arms
holy [ __ ] he has no ring on it okay
I don't know how do I answer although I
dress up so nicely men avoid me rather
than approaching me I feel so I I think
it has something to do with your harms
girl uh do you know a part of chance if
that man with a so check it ok let's are
you this suit no you're not alright
that's absurd there's absolutely no
served in this place typical horror game
scenario hey or a horror movie
do you know that those pays of $10 I'm
having a pretty interesting okay
I think it's time to keep going I don't
know what we're supposed to eat in track
there are guests in my house I can't
leave them well [ __ ] though they suck
this is some weird subtlety with these
[ __ ] games that just makes me makes
my butt chicken butt cheeks clinched
there are guests in my house I can't
leave them alone Edgar I'm happy to help
with dinner you're not to be honest I
shouldn't be help I have you seen the
kindergarten room I supposed to babysit
em but as soon as I knew about this
party I couldn't have could you pass me
the knife at the table please
I'll cut the bread so we can serve it is
that the bread that looks like a pudding
stew well I'll be darned
let me get that knife oh I can stab
people with it holy [ __ ] how about I
stab her
no job loss what what what what
no what you you GU didn't see [ __ ] oh my
god you stabbed her you killed I helped
a killer
if stop what I didn't stab her calm
yourself
this is striking this is not calm okay
all right she's fine she's fine
hey hey guys I don't know what you saw
let's keep partying come on I need to go
down the basement of this I became
dubstep for some reason hey lady you
don't win I just hide you don't you're
back here huh hey little my mommy what
are you alright I'm coming for ya let go
boy
coming for you oh yeah this is so cool
it's such a cool concept or is it gonna
stand this [ __ ] out of you
you saw me cut up the bread why did you
go little boy I know I locked the gate
no one can escape this place that's why
I made it this place it will all burn
after I stab their butts one by one I'll
go from left by cheek to right by cheek
all day son now reset well [ __ ] alpha
leader help you again huh
god dammit I wonder where he could've
went he probably didn't go in the closet
I'll be on my way now booyah oh
nevermind where did he go what do you
want whose job blood I saw hands get her
hands get the boy what where is he where
is he where is he
[Music]
Oh Oh you try to run oh I love it when
they run
come here little barman come here pop up
is that a duck holy Sh I don't distract
me with duck see Peter you're rocking
with the Ducks aren't you dead duck what
do you what do you want shut up [ __ ]
don't judge me duck you didn't see [ __ ]
you know what else poor little boy ran
right like him I feel bad says is it
little boy I can do that I feel like
it's the point of the game for me to
kill him so I'm gonna kill him it's not
doesn't have anything to do with Martin
lang little children just it's just okay
I just don't want to mutilate what are
you going round little boy don't judge
me
he deserved to die Oh
what don't you run from me don't you run
from me
Oh oh god what the [ __ ] she's fast as
hell come back little girl come back
come back I'll find you a bed sure
mm-hmm
this game is bringing out really weird
side of me I [ __ ] love it
you stop judging me god damn it there
you are
juice Kedah what didn't death what do I
want I want you all to pay for judging
my dancing I was being very subconscious
self conscious about my twerking and you
guys laughed you guys [ __ ] laughed
I don't know get the [ __ ] out oh oh my
what do we have here ah but does oh and
Layton elephant prove me right there
poor little it just being the troll Oh
call the cops huh
Karla Casas and gotta save you hmm my
little boy what are you doing out in the
street don't you know you can't get hot
I love it when they run
don't prolong the inevitable
oh you're running to your mama
shut up oh you're bleeding now well you
should've thought about ice [ __ ] before
I stopped you you dumb don't judge me
dont you judge me
you're a [ __ ] deviant i lap is there
anyone who wants to play come play with
me please I want to be your friends we
can play together we just had a party I
don't understand
everything was fine wasn't it oh you're
crying now oh you're merging with your
husband he's trying to protect you oh
that's adorable you see that moose
that's so cute you're not a moose
well why god damn are you named a deer
what the [ __ ] I mean I've been swindled
alright dear whatever
you're crying crying isn't gonna stop
this giant asteroid holy [ __ ] I told his
views you bet
or all your husband's they are you you
run well I took care of the other one
look at me when I stand up there's no
one to help you I live in a small
cottage isolated from down silence is
Lorelei in such a place
my home is always something I can turn a
inescapable prison while that charming
of the sparrows in the breath of the
window my solo company I like the sound
after wind
[Music]
so calm seriously I'm super impressed by
this that was so cool I know I gotta
fill out of my hand but that's so cool
for me play a lot of horror games I
really see the same [ __ ] getting
recycled you know dark horde thick or
thin corridors jump scares and and that
the game be ends and it just gets old
you know it's its effect everybody gets
old so seeing when stuff like this is
innovative and original it's really cool
I really appreciate work like this being
done anybody's enjoyed watching
obediently freak out too much so they
were like I've enjoyed watching and I'll
see you best in the next one it's a
spread of you
[Music]